the iphone 14 pro is getting a  groundbreaking new feature that is going  to literally change the world and  disrupt the entire smartphone industry  forever and it's coming in just one week  at apple's september 7th event and that  feature is satellite connectivity yes  with your iphone 14 pro you'll be able  to go out in the ocean out hiking  somewhere with absolutely zero cellular  service and you'll be able to send a  text message directly from the  satellites to your phone to somebody  else if you need help or if you just  want to text message someone which is a  groundbreaking new feature because right  now you actually have to buy a satellite  phone or satellite radio and even pay  for a monthly subscription in order to  do that but not anymore with the iphone  14 pro and i think the rest of the  smartphone industry is gonna follow in  apple's footsteps so i'm super excited  for apple's september 7th event